c'est très facile de critiquer l'action
ou l'inaction gouvernementale après coup
mais je veux dire que bon on est dans un
pays aujourd'hui où il faut se rendre à
l'évidence où la liberté d'expression
n'existe plus c'est à dire que
clairement quoi qu'on en dise même si on
ne peut pas droit ce soir à d'autres
grands discours sur le mouv agron
l'islamisme je lisais à l'instant le
tweet du ministre de l'éducation
nationale nous laisserons pas faire etc
etc
aujourd'hui je crois pas que si vous
voulez que lundi matin il y ait à
travers le territoire ne serait ce qu'un
professeur d'histoire ou de lettres qui
daignent prendre le risque si vous
voulez d'exposer les images des
caricatures donc l'islamisme a gagné de
longue date
aujourd'hui si vous voulez là ce sont
des postes adolescents qui terrorise la
france et des professions entière c'est
un fait
donc si en 2017 au moment où nous avons
voté on nous avait dit qu'il y aurait un
attentat de cette violence de cette
ampleur sur le territoire français et
que la cellule de crise serait présidée
par marlène scapa pendant que monsieur
darmanin se trouverait au maroc
je pense que personne ne l'aurait cru